>> CHANEZON: Cool. I think everybody is here
so we can get started. Hello, everybody. My
name is Patrick Chanezon. I've been a developer
advocate at Google since five years. I was
actually the first one hired to do developer
stuff at Google. And I've been to Brazil twice
already, GDD last year and some dev-fest a
few years before so I met a few friendly faces
here. So like Eric Tholome, I am very French
like you can see in my accent. And like Eric
said, in France we like to come on bare and
wine and cheese. This is Super DuPont, that's
our national hero. But we also like to work
with our heads like in this case. However,
contrarily to Eric, I think soccer is just
an area where French and Brazil just get along
together really well like this picture proves.
And so let's talk about cloud computing. That's
the topic of my talk today.
Okay, so just a reminder, there's a mobile
agenda for GDD so if you have an Android or
a smartphone, you can get there and you can
get feedback about the session in there, and
you can see all the agenda and all that. So
today, we're going to talk about cloud computing.
There are two talks about it. This one will
be about platform as a service offering which
is Google App Engine and Google App Engine
for Business. And then I have another talk
this afternoon if you're interested about
our new infrastructure as a service, services,
which is Google storage for developer, the
Prediction API and BigQuery. So if you're
interested in cloud computing, come to both.
Today we're going to talk about Google App
Engine. The new features in Google App Engine,
a little bit about the roadmap, some details
about Google App Engine for Business which
is the new thing that we unveiled at Google
I/O in May and that is in trusted tester right
now. And then, we have a guest speaker Phillip
Klien from BTBucket. He's going to tell us--Mario,
this morning, told us about the business aspect
of how BTBucket is using App Engine and he's
going to tell us about the technical aspect.
And I think he's driving from the airport
right now. So before I get started, I'd like
to know a little bit more about you guys.
Who here is using some kind of cloud platform,
whether Amazon or Microsoft or Google? Okay,
not that many. I guess it's less than 5%.
Any Google App Engine users here already?
Wow, the same 5% so all of you guys are using
App Engine. That's great. That's a good start.
So what is cloud computing? Cloud computing,
there are a lots of talks about this these
days because it began fashionable. It started
to become fashionable this summer when Gartner
has this hype cycle for technology adoption.
And this summer, cloud computing started to
get at the top of the hype curve, which means
that during the year, it's going to go down
into the trough of disillusionment. But we
don't care about that because we're developers.
We're just going to build stuff with that
kind of infrastructure. If you're interested
in definitions about cloud computing, there's
a great talk, I forgot his name, at OSCON
by a guy name Simon--I forgot his last name.
A very good talk where he goes over the 15
different definitions of cloud computing.
Basically, to me, cloud computing is all about
industrialization of software infrastructure.
Industrialization and automation. There's
a great book by Nick Carr, that's called the
Big Switch that explains that what we're going
through right now is a revolution similar
to the industrialization of electricity at
the beginning of the 20th century where, basically,
we're going instead of each company having
their own data center you're going to use
some utility computing and just pay in a metered
way. And that's exactly how electricity was
industrialized at the beginning of the 20th
century when lots--every company had their
own powered generators and they started buying
electricity from utilities that built huge
plants. So we're seeing that move in computing
these days. It started, I should say, around
10 years ago. And right now, it's reaching
critical mass where you start to have real
utility computing that is available. What's
really interesting about this field that it's
blooming. There's tons of startups as well
as big companies experimenting with various
play sets of that so the market is quite complicated
and there are a lots of offerings in there.
The way the analyst traditionally view that
market is with three layers. The first one
is infrastructure of the service. That's what
companies like, Joyent or Amazon are doing.
Basically, it's renting VMs, you just provision
your VMs in the cloud. It's very flexible
but the disadvantage of it is that you still
have to manage all that stuff. And so there
are some companies like RightScale that provide
you some admin consoles for managing all that
but still there's lots of work to provision
all the VMs and build your own scalable infrastructure
on top of that. On top of that, there's another
layer called platform as a service. This is
what Google App Engine is. In a platform--and
there are some other frames like Windows Azure
or force.com. The concept of platform as a
service is you write your code, you push it
to the cloud, and then the cloud provider
manages everything like the load balance or
the number of the front-end servers, number
of backend servers and replication the data
store and replication between different data
centers. So the disadvantage of these platforms
is that you need to abide by the limitations
of the platform provider. So I'll tell you
about Google App Engine. There are few limitations
in there. For example, you need to code in
Java or Python if you do PHP or oblige to
go to infrastructure as a service. But if
you abide by these limitations, it buys you
a lot of flexibility. You just can't concentrate
on your code and you don't need to worry about
scalability. And then at the top layer of
that is software as a service which is what
Google Apps or salesforce.com are about. And
there's a big explosion of software as a service
these days. Most software is becoming as a
service, and as companies are building more
and more of type of software that use to be
done as client applications provided as a
service, they more and more rely on cloud
computing for that. The way I describe Google's
exposure of cloud computing is pretty much
like a striptease. So we started with a software
as a service with Google Apps. We've provided
Gmail and Google Docs and all that to all
companies. After that, we just unveiled one
layer and we exposed our platform which is
Google App Engine. And then more recently,
we started unveiling even more and starting
to expose our infrastructure like Google storage
for developers. So I talked about the value
proposition for infrastructure as a service.
It's very flexible but you still have to manage
all that stuff yourself. Now, platform as
a service is much easier. Google App Engine's
value proposition Eric talked about it this
morning. I won't go over that for long. It's
like build, manage, and scale. It's easy to
do all that. And our motto in the App Engine
team is, "We wear the pagers so you don't
have to." And I think it's a pretty good--pretty
good explanation of what we do. Numbers are
really good, I think, Eric showed them this
morning, 90,000 developers and 130,000 apps
and 700 million daily pageviews. This is a
Wordle, like a tech cloud of words about an
App Engine. It's all about applications and
data and request and data store. Lots of partners,
lots of companies have started using App Engine
for their apps. Initially, when we launched
App Engine in 2008, the first type of companies
who adopted it on mass where mobile and social
companies. Companies who have hockey stick
curve type of adoption where from one week
to the other they have two more million users
and there's no way they could manage that
to have their own infrastructure. So for this
type of companies like BuddyPoke on Orkut,
App Engine was really a boon. Now, that app
engine has matured and we have added lots
of feature, there are more and more enterprise
companies and ISGs who start to build their
apps on top of App Engine. And BTBucket is
going to come to talk at the end of this talk
to explain their experience. Socialwok is
another good example. They're doing social
networking for enterprises and they are integrated
with Google Apps in the Google Apps Marketplace.
Best Buy is another example of enterprise
use. BuddyPoke, very famous on Orkut, and
they've been one of our poster children since
the beginning. Lots of social apps like Gigya
as well. And what's interesting about Gigya
is if you look at the kind of spikes here--so
you see the spike there, App Engine is very
good at managing spikes. So, why App Engine,
I talked about that before. If you're hosting
by yourself or either, you know, you have
lots of hidden costs. If you're using infrastructure
as a service, you have lots of hidden cost
as well, you need to manage all that stuff.
So, what's in App Engine? So you have SDK,
the hardware, networking, we take care of
everything. But you're limited to two languages,
Java and Python. In terms of features, we
provide you a lot of services that are just
connectors to internal infrastructure at Google
in the form of APIs. So the services we have
are Memcache, the Datastore, which is called
Bigtable, URL Fetch, Mail, XMPP, Task Queues,
Images, Blobstore to store big files, and
a User Service. To language runtimes, we try
to make App Engine use standards whenever
we can so that you can port your app outside
of App Engine if you want to. In order to
do that, what we do is that we use standards
whenever they exist. So for example, App Engine
in Python is using the WSGI, which is the
standard for Python Apps, and you can run
Jungle applications there. For Java, we're
using Servlets and JDO/JPA. For the URL Fetcher,
we're using java.net.URL and javax.mail for
the mail and all that. So we try not to ring
event APIs. And the result of that is that
there are some developers who took the App
Engine SDK which is open source. And the App
Engine SDK is open source, you can run it
on your laptop to just do your development
and when you're finish you push it to the
production server. Some developers at a university
in the U.S., they created this open source
project called, I think, it's a Python IE--Python
IE were they took the App Engine SDK and they
plug it into scalable components--oh no, it's
called App Scale. So they plug that to scalable
open source components, like for example,
they replaced Bigtable with [INDISTINCT].
So that now you can run your private cloud
inside of your company if you want to and
use the same technology that you're using
with App Engine. So that kind of ensures the
portability. Another aspect that's interesting
is that, because we have Java, there are lots
of languages that run on top of the VM. So,
Scala, JRuby, so you can build rails application
with App Engine using JRuby, Groovy. Quercus
is a version of PHP that runs on top of the
top App Engine but I'm not sure how solid
it is, I haven't tried it myself. You can
do JavaScript with Rhino and there are even
people using Jython on top of Java instead
of using App Engine Python because they want
to use other Java APIs. The pricing for App
Engine, it's free to get started. You have
a five million pageviews per month, a free
quota. So that's a lot. That means that as
long as your application don't get serious
volume, App Engine is free for you. Then if
you start to get into the more than 5 million
page views you pay for what you're using.
But at this point we expect that you'll be
able to monetize your app, and so you're paying
for bandwidth and CPU and storage, and all
that. When you're--so there's a dashboard
that shows all your application health and
stats, and you can view the data store and
all that. And there's a system status console.
In terms of developer tools, we have the App
Engine launcher that you saw Python and I'll
show you that. And then--and there's a console
in there that you can use, there's a plug-in
for Eclipse and it's constantly evolving.
So that's the timeline for the past two years.
Basically when you look App Engine, if you
looked at App Engine in 2009, you should take
a look again because there are lots of capabilities
that have been added since then. So the big
things were the Python launch, the Java launch
and then App Engine for business in May. But
in between these release is we add lots of
more features. So, something that's were pretty
important was XMPP support, incoming email.
There are some companies like TweetDeck who
use App Engine only for the email service
because they found that this is the cheapest
way to send email that they found. The Blobstore
for storing large files. And then later on
an additional API for serving images in a
very fast way where we are using a Picasa
infrastructure. App Stats, if you're an APP
Engine developer I highly recommend to look
at that tool. It really lets you--it's a server
side profiler. It really let's you see which
pieces of your code are taking the longest
time to run. I think URL Fetch allows you
to fetch many URLs in parallel in the same
request. And then OpenId, Oauth, and better
Bulkloader back in May. So what's new? One
of the new things is the Multitenant API.
It's called a Namespace API. It allows you
to--it makes it easier for you to go Multitenant
applications. So, first time I heard about
Multitenant, it was all in the salesforce
lingo and I thought, "Wow, what the heck is
that? What does that mean?" And what that
mean is very simply. It means you have just
one web application and it can be used by
many different domains. And each of these
domains will have separate data stores. So
instead of provisioning separate apps and
separate data stores, just use the same app,
same data store but then you just have an
API to say, "Oh, when I'm making this call
into the data layer, just prefix it with this
Namespace which corresponds, for example,
to the company domain or something like that,
and then you don't need to worry about it."
So that's a very easy way to build these Multitenant
apps. And it is especially important because
more and more Google Apps Marketplace applications
are using App Engine and they need to be Multitenant
in order to participate in the Marketplace.
High performance image serving, I told you
that. Now, when you put an image in the Blobstore,
instead of it being served relatively slowly
from the Blobstore you can elect to use the
Picasa service to just serve your image really
fast and crop to a certain size and all that.
OpenId and Oauth integration, Error Pages,
we have--we increased lots of good quotas
that we were limits for developers. You can
now pause Task Queues from the console. And
there's a lot of stuff. You should check our
blog for all the features. Now, there are
three up and coming features that I think
are really important and will help you build
a new kind of app in App Engine. App Engine
traditionally has been targeted at just building
web apps but there's a lot of stuff in the
web app that needs to have asynchronously
were your messaging, your data, you do migrations,
you clean up your data, you do reporting and
all that, all that aspects has slowly evolved
into App Engine. First, we have Task Queues
and now there's three APIs in the pipe that
will help you do this heavy duty processing.
First one is called the Mapper API. Who among
you have heard about MapReduce? Any MapReduce
users here? Okay. So for those of you haven't,
I highly recommend the MapReduce papers by--that
was done by Googlers maybe 10 years ago or
eight years ago. MapReduce is--it's a notion
that comes from 30 years ago from list but
it's been re-implemented in C++ by Googlers,
like eight years ago, in order to build our
batch processing pipeline. So MapReduce is
what we're using internally at Google to compute
the search ranking and do a lot of background
processing, batch processing that happens
asynchronously. The concept of MapReduce is
very simple. You just have--instead of building
a long program that will act on your data
you just cut it down into small parts containing
two essential operations. One is called map
that selects a specific set of data from all
the data stream that you're going through
and all this is happening in parallel on lots
of different servers. And then the second
one once your Mapper has done their job they
can push the entries that they have done into
a reducer, into a reduce operation, and Reduce
takes lots of records and then reduces them
to a single data or a single record or something
like that. And this is a very simple concepts
that you can--if you can reduce lots of your
processing to this paradigm it lends itself
very well to parallelization. So once you
have coded your stuff in MapReduce, basically
you can have the underlying infrastructure
run it in parallel on thousands of servers
and huge sets of data. So in App Engine today
we don't have reduce yet but we have map and
map can be very useful. So what map allows
you to do is--for example to do a report generation
or to clean up your data store. For example,
you can have a map that just go over all your
records and look for a specific field and
remove it. Brett Slatkin from the App Engine
team who's maintaining the PubSubHubbub project--if
you want to hear more about that, come to
my social session later, so he has a huge
PubSubHubbub public hub that's used by lots
of people with I think maybe a terabyte of
data; like huge number of records, millions
of records in there. And this is an App Engine
app and he was one of the first one to use
the Mapper and what he did is that all his
data was taking too much space so he just
wrote a map, sent it to a Mapper and said,
"Just execute this," and the Mapper was a
few lines of code just to remove one field
from all that. And I think it's run nonstop
for eight days or something like that on lots
of servers and he--I need to put the link
in there, but he put a buzz entry above this
and it was pretty impressive. So Mapper API
is coming soon. Another important aspect for
building apps is something called Comet, which
is where the server is pushing some data to
your clients. For example, when you're in
Gmail, you receive notification that your
Gmail, there's new mail for you. So in order
to build that kind of apps in App Engine it
was impossible before because you have a 30-second
limit for every HTTP request so after that,
there's no way to keep a connection open to
the server so you have to pull. In order to
make that kind of apps possible, we're releasing
a new API called the Channel API. That's a
conjunction of a client-side library and a
server-side component API that will basically
allow you to use an API that's very similar
to WebSocket in HTML5 in App Engine apps.
And what that allows you to do is to have
some test queues on the server that can push
some results to the browser. So that's pretty
impressive. And there's some demo code already.
If you want to participate in this one, it's
in trusted tester right now. It's not generally
available yet. And then the last one that
was announced last week in the Google Group
for developers is called the Matcher API.
So Matcher API allows you to register some
queries to match against incoming documents
in the database but shoots your documents.
So it's not like map where map is acting on
your existing database. Here, you're setting
matchers for specific criteria on the future
stuff that's going to enter your database.
And then we have some powerful infrastructure
of it that's going to run that in parallel
in a very efficient way instead of running
test queues by yourself where basically your
criteria or your query is going to be execute
every time there are some new documents coming
in the system and then that query can do something
with it like increment a counter, create a
new record, send an email or whatever. So,
this one is in trusted tester as well. And
I think there's a signup sheet in the Google
Group. I'll push my slide on slide chair a
little bit after this talk so you can find
all these URLs. Now the App Engine Roadmap,
I think Eric talked about it this morning.
We have bunch of stuff in the pipe. For me,
the most exciting one is background servers.
One of the things that you cannot do with
app engine is not designed for that is to
have long running processes like they do some--so
we have test queues which are limited to a
specific time that can run in the background.
But these background services you could connect
to them and so you can implement a much richer
set of applications with that. So, these ones
are on the pipeline. All the rest, dump and
restore, like all the rest is like pretty
much we talked about it. Another important
aspect is reserved instance. Reserved instances
are available in trusted tester today so if
you need that, ping me, and I'll put you on
the list for that. Reserved instances allow
you to book--yes, to book an instance, a specific
instance for your App Eapp. When you push
your App Engine app to App Engine, you don't
know which server you're running on, how many
instances they are. You don't have any control
of that and that's a little promise of platform
as a service. Now, in some cases, that's a
problem. Like for example, when you're using
heavy frameworks in Java that take a long
time to load, the first request is going to
cost a lot. So there's going to be a lot of
this 30-second that is taken by the framework
loading. And it's even worse when you're running
interpreted languages on top of the VM, like
JRuby for example. So for that type of app,
it's really slow to start. And because that's
a problem, reserved instances, you will be
able to pin down your application to a few
instances. And that's where you pay that price
for the warming request only once and you
can do that at Startup. So, that should solve
a lot of problems. Now Google App Engine for
Business, so, that's the new stuff that's
being announced at Google I/O last year. It's
very similar to Google App Engine but it's
trying to address a different use case which
is lots of people are building public web
apps with Google App Engine. But since 2008
when we shipped it, I've been talking to lots
of companies and they come to me and they
say, "Oh, we like the flexibility. We like
not to have to worry about all that infrastructures
and stuff. We like to use App Engine for building
our internal apps but basically, you guys,
are bozos. There's no SLA. There's no paid
support. There's no SQL support. I need that
because I have some existing apps so I just
cannot use it." So basically what we did is
that we responded to this market demand by
created Google App Engine for Business to
specifically address this use case of building
internal apps for companies, for Internet-type
of applications.
So App Engine for Business is the same platform
as App Engine with a few enterprise specific
features in there. So the first one is what
we called the domain console that allows you
to provision your apps from a single console
for the whole intranet. So you don't need
to depend on the main name space from appspot.com,
you can create whatever apps in there directly
in the console. There's a 39 SLA. There's
premium developer support. There's SQL support
as well. And so, that will be available as
part of App Engine for Business. SSL for your
domain. But then this is targeted at enterprise
apps, which means these are apps where you're
building internal apps and you're a company
who have build Google Apps for your domain
so every user will have a Google Apps for
your domain log-in and all these apps will
be authentified so you need to authentify
in order to go to these apps. You cannot build
apps that are public on the Web. And the pricing
is different. So the pricing is $8 per active
user per month for--and per application. So
the--all that stuff, this is the status of
that. So the admin console is in preview.
If you're interested in trying it out for
your enterprise, contact me and I'll put you
on the list. Direct phone support as well.
Hosted SQL, it was available since two or
three weeks, it's very recent. So if you have
a used case and want to play with that, shoot
me an email. I wanted to do a demo but I will
lack time. And billing and all that will come
later in this quarter. Okay, so now maybe
I will--maybe I will do--let me see, I will
just show you a very quick demo before Phillip
can come in, so. Yeah, I know. Let me show
you my console. So this is my, actually this
is my regular console. So that's my regular
console for App Engine. That's what it looks
like here; I was looking at the logs. I actually
deployed my first SQL App today. I've been
waitlisted last week. And I can show you the
SQL App in--so this is just a servelet in
Java, so that's in Eclipse. So I have a servelet
here. It's a very simple servelet. I just
register the new driver, SQL driver, that
we have in there. So I get a connection to
my database. And then I can execute SQL commands,
it's just a JDBC driver. So that's what I
did and I just deployed it before coming here.
So it--yeah. Today, just insert the statement
in the database. I need to make that example
a little bit better. I just wanted to show
you that that stuff works. But then I wanted
to show you the admin console. So this is
the new domain console. I have it for my chanezon.com
domain where I manage all my family's applications.
So let's say, I'm a small business and I have
this console. And here you can see that I
have a few applications and I could create
a new application, and it's an app engine
for business application, and it's going to
be automatically in my X.chanezon.com domain
extension. And I created it there and I don't
need to go to the regular app engine console.
Then the new admin console also lets me do
things like specify who in my company is allowed
to do what. And then this is an example of
an app engine for business application for
my domain where here you can see I have deployed,
it's an open source blogging engine written
by Nick Johnson, one of my colleagues. It's
called "blog art" and I deployed it in app
engine for business inside of my domain which
means that if a user on the Internet who's
not logged in to my domain just tries to get
there, so I'm just going to create a new incognito
window so I'm not logged in here. If I go
there, he will ask me to login to the Chanezon
family. So I need to be part of the domain
to use that. And just to deploy that you just
check out the code, put your app I.D. in there
and deploy it, it takes five minutes. So on
that, I'm welcoming Phillip Klien from Predicta
and BTBucket. He's going to tell us about
the technical aspect of how the user App Engine...
>> KLIEN: Thank you.
>> CHANEZON: Thanks for coming, Phillip. He
just comes back from the airport, so thanks
for coming today.
>> KLIEN: Thank you. Hello. Hello. [SPEAKING
IN FOREIGN LANGUAGE] hosting [SPEAKING IN
FOREIGN LANGUAGE] app engine [SPEAKING IN
FOREIGN LANGUAGE] Java [SPEAKING IN FOREIGN
LANGUAGE] Java [SPEAKING IN FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
Python [SPEAKING IN FOREIGN LANGUAGE] app
engine [SPEAKING IN FOREIGN LANGUAGE] App
Engine for business, so [INDISTINCT] get back
to follow a key [SPEAKING IN FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
I just think [SPEAKING IN FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
app engine [SPEAKING IN FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
Google [SPEAKING IN FOREIGN LANGUAGE].
>> CHANEZON: [SPEAKING IN FOREIGN LANGUAGE].
Thanks, Phillip. And just to conclude, we
have Yara Senger from Globalcode.
>> SENGER: Thank you very much. And since
he mentioned, I'll start the talk to the Globalcode.
I'm going to start [SPEAKING IN FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
Java and [INDISTINCT] [SPEAKING IN FOREIGN
LANGUAGE] Globalcode [SPEAKING
IN FOREIGN LANGUAGE] global [SPEAKING IN FOREIGN
LANGUAGE] and also--and also [SPEAKING
IN FOREIGN LANGUAGE] Google [SPEAKING IN FOREIGN
LANGUAGE] Google App Engine [SPEAKING IN FOREIGN
LANGUAGE] Android [SPEAKING IN FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
the
Google [SPEAKING IN FOREIGN LANGUAGE] Google
Technology User Group [SPEAKING IN FOREIGN
LANGUAGE] Google App Engine [SPEAKING IN FOREIGN
LANGUAGE] Globalcodes [SPEAKING IN FOREIGN
LANGUAGE] Google
App
Engine
[SPEAKING
IN FOREIGN LANGUAGE] Google App Engine
IN FOREIGN LANGUAGE]